here's a story from
CNN US Marine rapid response force
moving toward Israel as Pentagon
strengthens military posture in region I
love how they're very careful with their
headline let's be real this is a
deployment but here's how they phrase it
as as after you read the headline moving
towards what does that mean a US Marine
rapid response force is headed to the
waters off the coast of Israel and the
Pentagon is preparing American troops
for a potential deployment to the
country esal ating the US's show of
force in the region as it works to
prevent the conflict between Israel and
Hamas from widening any further a
defense official familiar with the
planning said the rapid response Force
consisting of 2,000 Marines and sailors
is being sent it will join a growing
number of us warships and forces
converging on Israel as the US seeks to
send a message of deterrence to Iran and
the Lebanese militant group Hezbollah on
Sunday evening US Secretary of Defense
Lloyd auson ordered that roughly 2,000
troops prepare for a potential
deployment to Israel to help with the
tasks like medical and logistical
support multiple defense official says
uh in other words the US is entering the
war yes no no we're just entering near
the war war we're just moving towards
the War I hate that phrasing I think
that's so lame well we did that in Kiev
too because we have special forces in ke
MH hanging out and we haven't declared a
war since World War II so this is just
more run-of-the-mill well we don't have
a house speaker so we can't really
declare much of anything at all oh golly
what maybe that's good then though maybe
That's the Silver Lining to that
situation well the only issue though is
that of course Biden can do pretty much
whatever he wants which is what we're
seeing play out right now it's not
really Biden I mean Biden's staffers can
do whatever they want it kind of makes
you wonder about the timing because they
kept not working on Sunday or not
working Saturday not working Sunday not
working Monday and it's like they were
putting off this vote and now all of a
sudden there are Marines headed to
Israel without without Congress even in
session like I mean that's amazing yeah
that is pretty upsetting actually so so
here's what
happens I'm not saying this is
definitive absolute absolutely going to
happen but how do you as the president
get the us into a war without a
declaration from Congress well for the
most part they've just done it they just
send the troops they send us Marines and
warships into the Mediterranean they
send it into Israeli Waters and then
what happens when Hezbollah
attacks now you don't need a declaration
now it's we're being fired upon we have
to react our ships that we put there
ially are now under attack that's right
it's crazy how that happens what's Wild
is remember when they said Trump was
going to start World War III and how
Biden came in and said now the adults
are in charge and then he proceeded to
destroy everything how long until
they're like well actually this is all
Trump's fault in the first place anyways
if Trump had never been president I I
feel like they'll always say it but
there'll be some specific state
statement from Biden that's like
ultimately this is all Trump's fault
even though I have been in office for
basically thas would not have escalated
if not for Donald Trump doing nothing I
don't know he'll come up with well Hamas
has been planning this attack for 2
years which is basically when Biden took
office they started planning this attack
exactly because when Trump was in office
he was strong enough he had an
interesting quote today he was speaking
in Iowa and he said he said that his
personality had kept us out of War
that's not wrong it's entirely right I
mean as I've said about Trump in the
past like the thing about Trump is he
appears to be an absolute crazy man and
you stay away from a crazy man a crazy
man will do crazy things so you kind of
back off you let him do his whole crazy
thing and that's a big part of what made
him so effective is that he was
unpredictable you never quite knew what
kind of thing he was going to do right
down to the Abraham Accords which were
actually pretty genius because they were
these bilateral agreement well that's
kind of the opposite I mean it's not
just that Trump threatened to Nuke
Moscow and uh uh and what what else what
what else did he threatened Moscow and
China a little as well China which which
city was it he said he was going to
there was two cities nuke the out
of one right he said no no no he he has
that famous quote where he said he would
nuke Moscow and then and Beijing yes
yeah I'm like it's it wasn't Shen Jang I
mean that's not Beijing right of course
he also had that threat that he did on
Twitter at the time about like do not
come at me Iran or something like you
will you will experience like a hell
you've never seen before but I think I
think for Russia for instance they have
no reason to invade Ukraine When Donald
Trump is saying we're getting our troops
out of the Middle East this is
ridiculous you know what are we here for
oil and so that was a big part of the
conflict is the US basically trying to
force Russia's energy business into the
gutter and instead of competing on the
open market When Donald Trump starts
saying look we're not going to go to war
over this we're going to do energy our
way we're going to start drilling for
oil in the United States we've got
Alaska we could do all these things and
he did and gas prices go down now gas
prices went down dramatically every
people failed to mention this because of
Co cuz demand was in the gutter and they
had to give oil away it was crazy but
still was relatively cheap even before
this and so Russia's incentive for war
is minimal then you get the Abraham
Accords why because there's an economic
incentive now from the West I mean this
is brilliant stuff but but what happens
then is the the uh the left is arguing
that this conflict between Hamas and
Israel is Trump's fault because of the
Abraham Accords because it marginalized
and sidelined Hamas and their only
reaction was going to be military
conflict and I'll push back on that and
say if Donald Trump's policies were
still in place then the incentives of
Saudi Arabia and qar and the Emirates
Etc would be to align with Israel
because their deal is being jeopardized
by the actions of Hamas instead you get
Joe Biden and his administration that
doesn't care for these negotiations and
wants War well and that's exactly what
happened right you have Saudi Arabia
which was doing negotiations with Israel
they were cooling some tensions and now
that has totally been scuttled as a
result of the Hamas attack um so I think
that's been that's been pretty effective
and if if what the Biden Administration
wants is permanent War which it does
seem like that is what they're
interested in um then it would make
sense that they would continue to help
escalate the situation I mean it always
I can't help but think of months before
Russia invaded Ukraine there was that
phone call between Putin and Biden where
Putin said if you promise that they are
not going to join NATO we will not
invade Ukraine and I just can only
imagine you know I don't know what Biden
said in response other than no we're not
going to do that but I can only imagine
these two personalities we're not going
to have a productive conversation the
relationship between the US and Russia
was the strongest at least in most
recent years when Donald Trump was in
office because Putin respects him more
than he respects Biden yeah you also had
kamla Harris coming out saying that
Ukraine was going to join NATO at some
point you have all of these overtures
from the EU to bring Ukraine in and
Ukraine doesn't Ukraine like mean
Borderlands essentially yeah so if you
take Ukraine away then suddenly Europe
is and NATO and the EU are right on the
doorstep of Russia and that's a threat
to them like there needs to be right we
act they want this barrier right we act
like they're uh concerned that the NATO
border is being expanded directly next
to them is is sort of absurd when it's
not I mean you can disagree with all
kinds of other things but this idea that
this was one of the contingencies for
not invading and that Biden just said no
I'm against this and whatever you know
obviously we we're setting the Biden
Administration did not take steps that
were necessary to deescalate a situation
in fact now that we see that apparently
yen is like yes we can afford another
war of course they want another War
because who among them makes money
probably all of them we also have this
tweet from someone I don't know who but
it's under the Biden Twitter account X
account saying an attack on one group of
us is an attack on all of us in America
hate will not Prevail Venom and violence
against any one Community cannot stand
and will not be the story of our time
who's even who is he who is Karen
jeanpierre even talking about there is I
think talking about and talking to I
think it should be illegal for uh anyone
but the president to post from the
president's account I completely agree
uh but it should say like pus little
staffers or something the account that
should be the account pus staff but this
account should only be the president due
to the fact that it's public record as
statements of the President right I feel
like this is a statement from the Biden
administration at large it's not the
Biden himself that's true of the White
House I mean the White House puts out
statements all the time that to the
Biden to Joe Biden even though he is
unlikely to have written
them in the he would have read them and
signed off on them though I think that's
think he does that to all the briefings
no I don't even think this man reads any
of the briefings but that's because I
don't trust him it should be a legal
requirement that a president sign off on
any statement attributed to the
president for the sake of public records
yeah he should sign off on it before he
takes the documents and puts them in his
garage yeah that means if they want to
write them for Twitter for X then they
have to get approval from him and he has
to sign it he has to sign off on it yeah
I think that makes a lot of sense he has
to have his own tweets to have a I'm Joe
Biden and I approve this message why but
this is this is basically more war
postering right for sure the attack on
one group is an attack on all of us here
we go and they're going to say you're
either with us or the terrorists Etc
yeah textbook yeah but I don't think
that Joe Biden is in a position to argue
with his own staff right I don't think I
I personally think Joe Biden would be
happy go to war but on top of that he's
not checking his on Twitter he's not
reading the briefings I mean he is not
in a position to challenge whichever
staff are saying no Mr P president this
is a good line um I mean even last week
when we had him say I never thought i'
I'd be able to confirm he had that weird
statement about the the photos of the
children and then it was like white
house then fact checked him this didn't
happen which is not a great look I mean
Biden wants to go to war his
administration his staffers underneath
have their own reasons for wanting to go
to war and either way it's going to hurt
the American people well sure that's
what war does I mean unless we like uh
ramp up our Munitions and actually start
spending a lot of money and creating a
better War Machine and then getting rich
off that like we've done countless times
before that's also effective I'm kind of
noticing a pattern with how uh the way
we withdrew from Afghanistan and then
went to Ukraine kind of noticing like
they're kind of losing steam with the
Ukraine thing but now Israel's like the
next big thing so they're like yeah you
know it's kind of going to take a back a
back a back seat to the saon take look
at this must be so mad right now this
just popped up right now on the website
for the article we had us secretary of
state blinkin speaks after meeting with
Israeli War cabinet for more than seven
hours watch on CNN well we're not
watching CNN but that's the breaking
news right now he's speaking I wonder
what he'll be saying we'll pick up those
updates uh in a minute after they come
out you know outside of the video but uh
I think we're dangerously close to World
War II and I think it's a uh I mean
World War I what does it even mean uh I
think at some point within the next 12
months there's going to be a dramatic
and massive
mobilization I mean and and it's not
even a bold prediction to say something
like that we're looking at 2,000 Marines
and sailors deploying to Israeli Waters
and there's already warships there so
like if this
escalates WOW who could have seen that
coming Iran is to Russia as Israel is to
the United States in my opinion um so I
feel like if if like what Lindsey Graham
really wants to do this like he is just
so ready but if they if if we do
something to Iran that's gonna get
Russia involved it would be my fear and
that that would just be the escalation
and then if you have China and Taiwan
happening kind of over there and a
separate separate thing going on like
it's we're we're primed for escalations
everywhere everywhere I I wonder about
how this could play out I mean the US is
still the most powerful military force I
mean how many aircraft carriers do we
have we've got I think 11 active strike
groups and most other countries have one
mhm so we're we're pretty dang powerful
is a nation cuz it's probably more than
just a nation considering but I wonder I
mean does Russia and China enter this
Middle Eastern conflict under the guys
of the us is going to cause nuclear war
by you know and and and mass casualties
and we have to intervene what if what if
Russia and China decide to prevent us
involvement in the conflict entirely
they deploy troops into Syria and and I
don't know about Iran but perhaps I
don't know if that would be the most
strategic location well wasn't wasn't
Israel taking shots at Syria today in
Damascus they were today at the it's
been ongo non in Syria the Israeli
strikes on Syria have been happening for
a decade well sure but I mean just today
there was something specific you saw
today and Lebanon is targeting civilian
communities in Israel I mean this is
Israel evacuated some of the north y you
know um yeah Biden is going to visit
Israel next week now for all those who
are saying like I don't care about War I
don't know any about this stuff like
okay well you know your gas prices are
going to quadruple mhm you know $7 gas
yeah a lot of these people are too young
to even remember after 911 what happened
with the economy and what happened with
the gas prices and you know like I don't
remember that yeah you don't I wonder
how how the us is going to hand not
because I'm young I just I just I didn't
have a car I I only you weren't as
affected by these things I I I have
questions bu gas three years ago I have
questions about the people who are
currently serving as the Marines who
will be deployed to this region what are
your questions well you know I have to
imagine there're on younger side likely
gen Z I doubt they're sending a bunch of
40-year-olds you know so
Millennials like mid to late 30s now on
average with some younger Millennials
down into like the I think what you
could be late 20s and be Millennial
right or no you can yeah yeah so I I I
think it's mostly going to be gen Z so
who who's the kind of person who wants
to enlist right now someone who wants to
do a lot of Tik Tock dances and be
filmed big on drag queens I've heard
this argument right now well do you guys
know that you can get cosmetic surgeries
if you enlist that's so fun that's so
cool yeah they'll they'll cut your dick
off for you yeah they'll do anything
there's an AR someone was like saying if
you uh tell the air force that you and
your wife are in a dispute because she
needs a boob job the Air Force would
like well to help your marriage this is
come I don't know if you imagine telling
like Roman soldiers join the Army and we
can cut your dick off for you I mean I
think the the I remember this when I was
you know graduating high school that uh
student loan debt was so crazy that I
knew a lot of people who were not
interested in military service but said
but if I if I enlist I could potentially
get it paid for through the GI and I
need to go to college to see able to
suceed and we've seen that argument sort
of collapse the last last couple years
enrollments down we know enlistment in
the military servic is down so
ultimately the the very few benefits um
to to enlisting in in the army or in any
sort of military branch are not as
persuasive as they once were my question
is um are they going to try and sell it
as a rallying point I mean after 911 we
did see a lot of an increase in military
enlistment people people saw it as their
National Duty and I don't think people
feel that sort of patriotic Pride right
now especially you know do you want to
be enlisted under Biden probably
definitely not they've demonized
nationalism completely like there's
there's nobody that's why they have a
hiring crisis because a lot of them
would be like I went to the service
because my father served and my
grandfather served thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net